maybe no yo Elza bet it's bigger no way
I bet it's no bro he doesn't care that
arrogance too aggressive wives yeah when
you're that aggressive you don't have
that fat oh there's no way he looks like
that and doesn't have a big dick I don't
know dude see Batman and Batman the
comic drew a dick and he's that's Batman
you know I'm saying yeah Batman has a
dick now there's a new comic eight
there's like this new like kind of
x-rated Batman that come out with and
they show Batman's dick that's how I
pictured this is an evil Romero these
[ __ ] Millennials that think they're
gonna rewrite history they're making
iron man a woman they're crazy yeah it's
just people are out of their [ __ ]
mind Captain America is now a woman yeah
well I'm just saying iron man's probably
gay everyone's it's this there's a weird
revolution right now in comics because
they're trying to sort of social justice
warrior up all the comedy all the comic
books what do you laugh at that it is
true it is true all Cogan's uh look at
this DC Comics sorry for showing
everyone Batman's penis that's yo Romero
bro yeah it's good-sized real that's not
real see that's a comic book and it's a
comic book that's by the way was created
in like what was let's just take a guess
when Batman was created I'm a gas like
1940 when he's in super old-school 1940
1950s DC right Batman's dick and mm
think about the guy drawing it I don't
have the biggest dick and just mad yeah
but maybe he thought that was massive
probably thought was the biggest thing
he's ever seen yeah I'm scared to watch
porn and then and then got backlash when
he's like what the [ __ ] if this was a
big [ __ ] and was like no dude for
Batman's Batman you pretty him Batman's
the weirdest superhero ever because he's
basically just a rich guy he's Elon Musk
were on steroids and getting fight he's
Elon Musk
yeah yeah basically that's what he is
with a bunch of stuff yeah no special
skills well he knows how to fight yeah
but he doesn't have any superpower
there's nothing he's still rich dude
that's why I got angry at that Batman vs
Superman well my [ __ ] Superman would
first of all he moves so fast he can
make the earth spin backwards in Reverse
time he has lasers in his eyes for God
there's no
but Batman Mansu that kryptonite
Superman wouldn't even got a suit on
that's not even a fight lex luthor of a
valiant like adversary for him that's
not okay this is bored keeps that dude
around like a sidepiece dude he's like
let this guy pretends kicking my ass
venom drops this weekend yeah Tom Hardy
huh you know what maybe I'm just a
debbie downer but I don't I don't know
it looks all right to me and I love I
know I love Tom Hardy too what venom is
like an evil spider man like what is
that
he's expired man's alien it's an alien
yeah he's an alien element that grabs
someone's body alien that merges with
his body
yeah and he's evil I know I know I know
I mean I guess it's better than remaking
the Hulk for the 98th time I'll take it
I mean how many spider-man's are there
now there's like 80 spider-man's
whenever Spidey my starts making some
money they're like nah player we got a
new one bro we got a new and Tobey
Maguire's my spider-man yeah if you're
spider-man is anyone else [ __ ] you yeah
[ __ ] you yeah that's the real spider-man
hell yeah it's like thank you k they had
two new ones since him right what is it
it's been to one guy that never even
Johnny traction Holland who [ __ ] Tom
Holland sorry Tom they wanted me you're
wonderful